Taking your time to
do some ideas.
No,
no,
it's great.
I was talking to Dave backstage.
We'd be trying to get our heads around
some of this and we were talking about
this idea that when
scientists look forward,
the intellectual dark,
we were trying to figure out what
it wants to do all them a in common,
you know,
people on that list ferry
sometimes insight on
Joe Rogan,
Dave and me and the Weinstein brothers,
a handful of other people,
and then one thing I can really think
of the United States is that we don't
think you're stupid.
That's what it is
because there's no reason to treat
an audience attempted to assume.
Then that works to assume that people
aren't capable of operating at a high
intellectual level to be compelling
as participate genuinely in soft,
simple discussion and perhaps discussion
that even goes deeper than that.
Then it looks like there's a real hunger
for that in the real demand for it
because you know you're not stupid.
Thank you.
So I'm going to talk to you about tonight,
but not exactly because what I want to
talk to you about is the thing is that
I've been thinking about the same topics,
but since I wrote the book,
because I'm always thinking about golf
and I don't like to use sad because
they're complex ideas,
not because because it's the topics,
they be continual development,
continual articulation,
continual reformulation.
So we'll stop there.
I'm going to walk from
the rules one by one.
I don't know how many,
but enough
to stand up straight.
Shoulders back.
In some sense.
I'm going to say to a limited
degree on someone like me,
I suppose
I have heard about hierarchies.
Isn't that one of the things
I was trying to point out,
which I believe to be
remarkably worth knowing.
Instead,
hierarchical structures are extraordinary.
Um,
if you looked at any critiques
of Modern Society Inboxes,
critiques,
let's be more precise because the left
has its purposes and all get to that
later.
But mom,
sister takes
the boxes,
are very much concerned
about the detrimental
consequences of hierarchies and
mostly what they're concerned
about to give the devil his due,
let's say,
is the fact that if you have a hierarchy
that people tend to stack up with the
blog and that's true,
that that is what happens.
It's.
It's a well documented effect.
Success tends to become
disproportionate and forth.
People Stack up at zero and so there's
a big price to be paid for hierarchies.
But the problem with the
Marxist is that they placed it.
They attribute a causes of hierarchy to
the wrong reasons and by doing that they
do a disservice to the very
people that they purport to help.
So if you lay the problem of hierarchy
at the feet of western civilization,
say or capitalism,
then you're way off the
mark and Ashley dependable.
And that's why I wrote about lobsters
in chapter one because the fact that
animals who are inclined to live in
social groups spontaneously organize
themselves into hierarchies,
doesn't justify the existence
of hierarchies ethically.
And that wasn't the point
I was trying to make,
but it certainly doesn't disprove the
idea that there would be laid at the feet
of western civilization or capitalism
because monsters are not part of Western
civilization and they're not capitalists.
That was part of a point.
It's actually really a problem when you
construct a hierarchy that people stack
up at the bar.
It's an issue.
It's a serious problem and it's a serious
enough submitted it repeatedly estabil
destabilizes civilizations.
In the past,
even if you look back
in the Old Testament,
when the prophets announced their
opposition to the Hebrew case,
one of the constant complaints about the
kings who became Arabic was that they
weren't paying enough attention to the
windows and the children right to the
dispossessed and so the
profits would emerge and say,
oh,
you,
you don't get it.
You're society is destabilizing
in an unusual way.
And that's an indication
that it's going to fall.
And then it actually
happens to be the case.
And so the fact that people stack up
at the bottom has to be contended with
because if the inequality distribution
gets to steep than the whole society
stabilizes and that was a very bad thing,
but that doesn't mean that
that still doesn't mean that you could
lay the issue of hierarchy at the feet of
western civilization or capitalism.
A good book that was published recently
and somebody to be interviewing in the
next.
He wrote a book called the great leveler
and he did it in technical analysis of
inequality and so what are the things
he did was mattress that you surveyed a
variety of left wing governments in a
variety of what great we'd governments and
you've calculated the need
for warranty coefficients,
which you do often,
something called the
Gini Coefficient tissues.
Then you can determine whether the
left wing governments tend to produce
societies that have more or less
equal tonight Greek governments.
What shutting off from was that there
was no effect whatsoever of political
ideology on inequality was a zero and
that's actually quite sad in some sense
because given a left wing,
governments are attempting to rectify
inequality and inequality actually happens
to be a problem.
It wouldn't actually be optimistic at
least to something intensive analysis if
there were to be in a relationship so
that the left wing governments work,
in fact presentable for societies
that kindness and equality,
but that's what happened
and starting off analysis,
which is quite striking,
I would say,
is that the only thing that
reliable reduces inequality.
The only he got into fights or factors,
but eating kind of boiled down
to two more and the illness,
so plagues and an outright
warfare decrease inequality.
Why flapping everyone and there's no.
He couldn't detect any effect,
any real effective,
viable,
any viable political effect.
So that's quite striking and it's well
known that system everywhere producing
quality.
The thing that that I think makes the
west remarkable or the free market,
let's say remarkable is that a along
with the producing inequality and also
produces wealth because it's easy to
set up the society that produces nothing
but a new quality,
no wealth,
and so maybe we should thank our lucky
stars that although we still suffer from
the consequences of the good quality,
we also live in a society with
a system that old socio culture,
let's say to also produce wealth and
then we don't have to start and our
children will have to start and
increasingly around the world.
People have to start
with and that's the best.
But I want to talk to you more about
hierarchies because there's something
really important apart from the fact that
hierarchies can't be laid at the feet
of political institution.
Stand apart from the fact that there
are no simple and easy political fix.
This.
There's something else that's really
important to think about with regards to
hierarchies.
Because you might say,
well,
even if they are ubiquitous,
even if they're everywhere,
even if they're grounded in biology or
already emergent properties of social
interactions.
Because either or both
of those could be true,
that doesn't necessarily mean the
tire or periods of good thing.
Maybe we should still just trying to
bring up and down and I would say that's
another trope of the left,
but I also think that that's
an extraordinary bad idea.
I think it's an impossible
idea first of all,
but north week,
is it an impossible idea?
I think it's a really,
really bad idea.
Here's.
Let me make sure.
I think that.
Can you see what you think about?
So there's kind of two
things that you want to
speaking maybe more on
me than anything else.
You want to limit your
exposure to existential terror.
Okay,
so you don't want to be too anxious and
you have your resistance will be added
to the center,
but he hasn't listened to
be anxious because of being
so self conscious that our
lives are or more when our lives are
fragile and we have reason to be anxious
and it's very difficult for us to
keep our anxiety under control.
So you don't want things to be too
unstable because it destroys you
psychophysiological.
It's not just a psychological phenomenon,
it destroys you physiologically
as well as psychological help.
Keep the complexity of those
certainty under control,
so that's like rule number one and rule
number two is it's not so bad to have
something to live for and that's.
That's actually a positive emotion issue.
So what the negative emotion.
So you want me to get the
motion control primary what?
Painting for sure,
but also anxiety and now
the positive emotion side.
Well you want to be satisfied now and
then they get what it is that you want and
need,
but but.
But that's a secondary
consideration in some sense.
Most of what you want is
something to strive for,
something to hope for somebody,
a map,
something that makes getting out
of bed in the morning worthwhile.
Let's call it a purpose.
Something that's meaningful,
something that you can engage with,
you have.
You don't even have a primary
psychobiological system that is actually
responsive to such space.
It's this has been.
It's activated by drugs like cocaine.
It's a system that wrote to a dope beat.
It had human being succeed,
particularly powerful because we seem to
be more motivated to chase things that
we want than we are to actually get the.
Have you been kind of notice
in your life because you don't.
Maybe you've had a bowl for years.
Well,
graduation is a good example,
right?
You're in college here in high school.
You're chasing this goal of
graduation and then you graduate.
Well then what?
Well,
then the game starts again the next day
after you graduate your local band on
the toilet bowl for
the next big adventure,
and so the fact that you attained your
goal doesn't mean that you stop at any
sense.
What it means is that you need to do
school and people need goals and so we can
take a little bit of.
You need more.
We've absolutely you need it for way more
than you think even and they can check
your hand.
For example,
I wrote a chapter called
be precise in your speech,
in that chapter lays out the fact that
this is a fact as far as I'm concerned,
that you can do that.
Look at the world without a goal because
your actual perceptions of the world
are organized around your value
structure and I don't even know if this
electrical metal,
the world's complicated to look at,
which is why it's taken so long to produce
machines that can see artificially.
We thought we'd have that problem solved
like 20 years ago or just getting there
now.
You can't see the world with other cool
and you can tell that because you point
your eyes and things and you point your
eyes to things that you're engaged with
an interactive thing.
So every single perceptual move you make
is an act of valuing and so he can't
even perceive the world without a okay,
so equal to sustain you in life.
And if people even to look at the world.
So let's think about the
consequences of having a goal.
Okay?
So the first thing is the thing.
You're not actually be
better than what you have,
right?
Unless there's.
Unless you're aiming
down and that's not good,
like people do it.
The guy who just read over
those people with the bat,
he was aiming down like seriously?
He was aiming to get out and so I
would say aiming down as a bad sign.
If you're aiming down,
you're in a bad way,
you're on a path to promotion and
maybe we'll take some people with you.
It's not a good thing,
so then you already know and you don't
want to eat too high up because what the
hell good are you,
right?
If it's.
If your goal is to Boffi,
then it's impossible it all you're going
to do is frustrate yourself to death
when we pursue it.
Not Thinking shouldn't be high,
but you shouldn't.
You don't want to punish yourself by
constantly reaching for things that are
continually beyond your grasp.
You wouldn't do that to a child
if you cared for the child.
We shouldn't do that to yourself.
I could say that you're a not.
Okay,
so what that means is what you're
aiming at is better than what you have.
That's a value proposition,
right?
There's value there.
Here I am,
but it's not where I want to stay
awake to go to the next place.
The next place is hypothetical.
You better.
I'm not sort of the basis of
the idea of mythological quest,
which is why the quest
story is everywhere,
right?
You've probably seen most of the pharmacy
20 movies in the last five years that
our quest stories and it's
because no one krasner.
You're after something,
right?
You go after whatever
it is that you're after.
You collapse a bit the way and you fail
and you fall apart and you put yourself
back together.
You have your adventure,
you told your story and that's life
and you have to have a question.
Hopefully you have a quest that sub
sufficient brand here so that it justifies
your life because that's really what you
want is you want to have a name that's
profound enough,
so the fact that you're finding
and suffering is justifiable.
You could get out of Gordon and think,
yeah,
well,
you know,
there's a lot of things about
life than a rough and harsh,
but I'm doing something that justifies
and then then you've got that.
You've got a meeting.
You've got a purpose of thank God for
that because otherwise it's bitterness and
hail all the way down
and so it's a good thing.
Have so now you pause your value.
You're ending up so now you've agreed
that there is an app because otherwise,
why would you put in an effort to attain
your goal if you did it implicitly
accept the fact that the you're aiming
at is better than the that you have,
so now you're also accepting a value
Schema of good and bad and being the
ultimate acceptance of the value
Schema of good and bad isn't even good,
bad.
Maybe it's good and evil.
If you talks about breakthrough,
it's archetipal poles and you live
in a landscape of good and evil.
That's the landscape of the quest.
Now,
here's the problem with
regards to hierarchy,
so let's let's say that you assume that
some things are worth pursuing and are
you going to do that in a social space,
right?
Because,
well,
hardly any.
If you were ever going to
do anything entirely alone,
I mean now and then,
but we're social right to the court were
cooperating and competing with other
people all the time,
so you lay out your quest
in a collective landscape.
That means that as you're
moving from point a to point b,
then you're going to be cooperating
and competing with other people.
You will be instantly produce around
your goal on organization of other people
and some of her peripherally
involved in and so forth,
but it doesn't matter
because the rop is this.
As soon as you punch that
something is worthwhile,
you produce a hierarchy because as
people cooperate and compete towards that
end,
doesn't matter what the end is.
Some people are going to end up being
way better at it than other people and
some people are going to be heard data
and so what will happen is that around
your value hierarchy,
you'll stack up pure middle hierarchical
structure that is composed of the
people who develop expertise
in relationship to that
goal and people who don't.
Now hopefully for the people who don't,
there are other games.
There are other value
propositions that they can play,
right,
because that's what you want
from a pluralistic society.
If your options are limited because
you're not good at one game and hopefully
there's no desk games live around that,
you can go participate in that.
I think that's one of the real geniuses
of modern society is that with any luck,
there's.
There's a critical place for
almost everyone and there.
Sure thing because if you
can't find the credible place,
well maybe that reflects badly on you,
but it's also possible that
reflects badly on the society.
It's not a good thing because
people need a critical place,
but the point is that construction
of a hierarchy is inevitable.
If you're going to accept the proposition
that some things are more valuable
than others,
and if you don't accept the proposition
that some things are more valuable than
others,
that is the reason to do
anything and you might think,
well,
who cares?
If there's no reason to do anything,
you know why you need a reason and the
answer to that as far as I can tell us,
because your life is very,
very difficult.
Like life is characterized
intrinsically by ineradicable.
Elbert are limited limitation and
suffering and there's no escape from that.
There's little rationalization of that.
There's no,
there's no denying that everyone
knows that can sometimes,
you know,
it's so painful you can bury them because
you know as social needs something to
make that worthwhile and if you're
going to play the game of making it
worthwhile,
they have to accept the value proposition.
And then what comes along
with that is the hierarchy.
So why are you going to do.
You're going to blow
up the value hierarchy.
So the value proposition.
So there's no hierarchy or what do you
leave people with that you really like to
know a then no goal,
no purpose,
no meaning.
It's like,
that's your cure map.
I'd like to see what the disease is.
It's not good.
So now we'll put that aside.
So
you can say,
well that's the hierarchy.
Doesn't a terrible aspect of a hierarchy
justified the value proposition?
Well,
that's a good question.
No,
I think we know what answered that too.
It's like,
let's say you,
you lay out the goal.
You might say,
well,
what's a good goal?
And that's a good inquiry to the
idea of what constitutes good,
but I think we're sophisticated enough
to have somewhat of a technical answer to
that and you can even see
this emerging unanimous cc.
So this morality that I'm laying out,
it's trends human.
It's,
it's,
it's sort of like the hierarchy issue.
You know when you see
hierarchies of human beings,
but you also see them in animals.
You see this immersion
morality and human beings,
but you also see it an Admin,
so it's deeper and broader
than human might say,
well,
if you're going to pursue
something that's good.
What are you going to parameterize?
What's good so that you know it's good.
Well,
here,
here's what the developmental
psychologists job piaget
came up with after
thinking about this for many,
many years of studying children at Piaget,
the who was the most outstanding child
psychologist or the 20th century was
motivated to do what he did because he
was turning to reconcile science and
religion.
It's not something that people know about.
Piaget,
much ship isn't,
isn't really advertised in university
courses dealing with fusion because it's
such a strange issue,
but he's a genius and he got offered
to curatorship of a museum because of a
paper we wrote on the Bolus.
Swimming was 10 years old and
his parents had been rejected.
They wrote back the people
who asked them and said,
well,
you know,
that's all very well and but he's had
anger is a financial genius and he had
this very interesting idea and so it's an
elaboration on scientific
elaboration of the,
the last for Daniel proposition.
So concert ethical proposition was
something like if you're going to act and
you're trying to figure out
whether what you're doing is good,
you should imagine that everyone will
do it and see if that would be a good
thing.
And so if it's universalized bubble,
then perhaps it's ethical.
So that's counts categorical imperative
and it's an interesting way to think
about it.
I think there's some utility in Psj are
the differentiated that quite nicely and
tall.
Articulate that a little bit.
So the first thing is,
so imagine you've got an aid
now and you're pursuing it.
You don't want to fix yourself.
May Room yourself tomorrow.
That'd be an impulsive and
you know what that's like.
That's like two bottles of wine at dinner.
That's,
that's great during Ganda,
but it's not so good
for you tomorrow anyway.
I think the hell with it,
it's worth tomorrow is that if you're
going to put forward the goal you want to
put forward,
the goal that stood for you right now,
but it's also good for moral but not
just tomorrow because you're not just
around tomorrow,
next week,
next month,
next year,
five years from now and so whatever it
is the uranian for should be sue you now,
but it should suit the array of
future use that are likely to manifest
themselves across time.
And so now the reason
I'm telling you this,
this is really important.
So I'm going to take a bit of a
side detour and then come back.
So the fundamental postpartum playing
this something like there's a near
infinite number of points to interpret
the world and so it's very difficult to.
Because of the number of
wasted to interpret the world,
which happens to be true by the way,
even technically,
which is why it's so
difficult to build machines,
to see the world because it's
very hard to see the world.
The fact that there's a number of ways
to the world does not mean that there are
a near infinite number of viable ways
of looking at the world and that's.
That's a crucial distinction
because it could give.
The postmodernist sister said,
well,
he stumbled on the problem
or multiple interpretations,
but they left it there.
It's like,
okay,
that is the problem.
Life is complicated.
How the hell do you
compute your way through?
It's really,
really difficult,
but for lots of things that
don't work like communism,
communism off the track,
thank [inaudible].
There's only two excuses for still
clinging to the idea of autonomy is works.
One is that you are historically
ignorant beyond all possible ethical.
What would you say?
Ethical reason,
or you're or you're willfully blind.
Three reasons or if real
from the glide or here,
so God damn Arabic that you think if you
wouldn't be standing that you invested
in me and told me on
the last point is very,
very,
very much more common than people think.
It's like,
well,
if I reverse the charge
of implementing communism,
it would have all gone well.
It's like,
no and absolutely what?
Especially if you're the sort of
person who actually thinks that.
Thanks.
Okay,
so from active liability,
so here's the constraints and NDC.
I think I could.
The thing I was so striking to me about
reading piaget and also a member of the
ankle experimentalists that I read who
are also interested in how morality built
itself from people like friends who all.
He studied chimpanzee behavior and he
felt just who studied both back behavior
and then complex social interactions
between animals and General Jaak Panksepp
who study the development of
a complex platforms in racks,
all pointed the same thing.
There's a morality,
but he merges off from the bottom up,
not from the top down.
Not Rational.
It's actually something that evolves and
it characterizes all sorts of different
species and players.
Um,
so,
okay,
so here's what's the set of constraints,
okay?
Your first is this first
constraint is constraints.
You can't pursue what feels good.
Now,
if it doesn't work leader,
and that's really complicated,
right?
Because it introduces
behind into the equation.
There's not just you,
there's the array of future use that you
have to take into account when you make
your decisions and that's
there's a multiplicity of
the future use and you don't
want to reduce that to
two to a greater degree,
right?
Because you don't want to set yourself
up so you don't have any options.
So you can't gratify her impulses
impulsively because if you do that,
then what you do is you sacrifice your
future self and if you want to be around
that,
that's a bad idea.
And so that's a major constraint because
it has to work now to all next week,
next month,
next year,
five years from now and so forth.
And so,
and you know that perfectly well in
this part of taking care of yourself.
So everyone has the sense of that,
whether it's articulated,
they're not.
I think your instinctual
sense of conscience,
you know that that sense that you have
with what's right and what's wrong is
actually part of the evolve moral
structure that guides you in a manner that
helps you take care of your potential
future self because otherwise you just
died stupidly.
You know at the more impulsive you are,
the more likely to die stupidly
and that you're getting.
That's the end of that.
Okay,
but that isn't,
that isn't the only constraint.
Even though that's a serious distress
in his note will be constrained because
you also have to deal with other people
and some of those people that are in
immediate proximity to you.
Let's say your,
your,
your immediate family.
You have to act in a way that works for
them because otherwise they hate you and
they torture you and they lead you or
things get better and horrible around you.
And so unless that's what you want,
that seems like a bad idea.
And so we have to foster their development
and the president and you have to
foster their future development.
And then you have to do that with
your family in a way that benefits
hypothetically benefits to the community,
the local community,
and the broader community.
And then again across
almost talking pretty.
So it's not like there's an
infinite number of solutions
to that set of problems
right now.
I think they,
what we actually recognize as
ethical behavior and which,
which I think we do naturally
recognize ethical behavior,
is that behavior that's in alignment
with that set of constraints.
And it's not something that
people discovered rationally.
It's not a rational imposition invention.
It's not a consequence of enlightenment.
Morality,
for example,
technically speaking of the enlightenment,
because lots of people,
um,
who are enlightenment rationalist,
believe that these propositions were
set forth in an articulate manner,
rationally be lightened.
But to me they go.
That was the gloss on top of something
that was far deeper Panksepp.
For example,
some of you probably heard
me talking about this before,
but panksepp demonstrated that
if you pair ras repeatedly,
juvenile rats who loved to engage
in rough and tumble play by the way,
which is extremely good
for developing rats.
If you want to develop some wraps,
that's how you do it,
but it's also really good for developing
little kids because they really like
rough and tumble play and there's
lots of complex reasons for that.
What panksepp observed was that if
you paired wrap dyads repeatedly,
so not just one game and who
played one game with someone,
right?
You played a game and then you
play the game again and again.
That's what being married is in play.
An infinite series of repeated Bill Gates.
And if you don't play the property
then it goes downhill very rapidly.
So what Panksepp observed was
that if you put it on Dale big,
rapidly wrapped together,
the pig gradlew stop a little
rap in their first contest,
but then if you parented repeatedly,
unless the big route that deliberate when
30 percent of the time a little robin
stop playing and so and it was up to
the little rabbit to invite the play.
So even among Ras,
there's an immersive sense of fair play.
Like literally there is divergence,
sense of fair play.
That's a consequence of having
to repeat the game over and over.
That's what so amazing discovery back.
I read that.
It just,
it just blows me away.
I think it seeds.
It's so funny.
You never know where we'll bolt,
which is going to come from because like,
what's peg doing?
He used to tickle rats with an eraser.
There's no.
What the hell is he doing?
Well,
it turns out that if you take
rat pumps away from their mother,
they got just like human infants to even
if you feed them and give them enough
liquid and keep them warm and everything,
if they're not cared for,
if they're not attached,
their gastrointestinal
system shut down in a dark,
exactly the same thing,
not to human babies.
So touch touch is a primary need.
So panksepp and people learn to massage
little rats with the racist pencil races
because they were gentle enough for
the ranch would giggle ultrasonically
because he recorded their,
their,
their vocalizations,
and they gave a little too sonically.
You couldn't tell them,
listen,
I don't know how to help
you ever figured it out,
but if you record them and
then slow down the tape,
you can hear them.
And so that would entice them into life.
So,
but the point is,
is that even among rats,
which are very social animals by the way,
um,
there are serious constraints on
interpersonal behavior that had ethical,
essentially ethical nature.
And so that's so cool because one of
the things that's really hard on her
culture is this emerging
sense of moral relativism.
That's it's a consequence of
an excess of rational thinking,
I think because rational thinker can
optimize any step of propositions and if
there's utility in that,
because it's part of thinking to be
critical and to be able to destroy things
and rebuild them,
but you don't want to destroy everything.
And one of the issues that's
immersed in the 20th century,
the drugs,
both nihilism and totalitarianism
as far as I'm concerned,
is the proposition that all value
propositions are something arbitrary and
equally print a sizable.
And I don't think that there's any.
I think we have enough evidence down
from categorically state the best.
That's just not true.
That whatever ethics constitutes isn't
arbitrary even though it's complex and
sophisticated,
but if there's any eradicable core and
it's predicated on something like the
necessity of iterating gates and all of
that emergence of morality that we can
then map.
And you know what this like.
Here's an example of this.
So imagine that you have no fun going to
get past the one actually magic pageant
that you're even,
let's say a talking to your son about
playing hockey or your daughter playing
soccer or whatever,
and um,
you know,
you,
you see them all the field and
they're kind of walking football,
you know,
and if you bring it back the way it made
me think of your soccer player and she
wins,
maybe she scores the winning goal,
but there's part of you this not too
happy about that because you know,
there wasn't any branded
scan along with it.
And so you're and off
the field and you say,
look Kiddo,
you know,
he did a great job in,
or maybe you're even the best
soccer player up there on the field,
but you know,
you read the play fair
and that's that idea.
And she says,
what do you mean I'm the best?
They're up there and I won.
And you're thinking,
well that's true.
And then you show up
because what do you know?
What are you going to say?
Because you don't know how to explain it.
You've gotten a sense that
something went wrong and he said,
well,
you know,
you have to let other
people have a chance.
Maybe she says,
well,
yeah,
but then we won't win.
So like,
no,
and you don't want to sleep.
You don't want to teach your daughter
to have Katie on the other players.
That's not what you're saying,
but,
but here's,
here's what,
here's what you know,
and this is so cool.
This is a good example of how it use the,
you know,
way more than you know,
which is also something really worth
knowing because you're really complicated.
You're way more complicated than you
think and way more complicated than you
even could know.
And you know,
all sorts of things that you
don't know that they'll have it.
You can't say so as you're quieter
than you are smart and some ways,
right?
Because otherwise we,
with Nita psychology,
we would have to figure ourselves out
and just be transparent to each other or
not.
So you have your daughter and you say,
so you were this little Kiddo.
There isn't a soccer game.
It's an illusion.
There's a sequence of soccer games.
And so if you are trying
to win the soccer game,
you're trying to win the sec of soccer
game and the rules for winning the
surface soccer games in not exactly the
same as winning what soccer game and you
don't want a win one soccer game in
a way that stops you from wanting to
separate.
Also forget.
And if you're gonna to
said of all soccer games,
maybe you're going to play
soccer for the next 10 years.
So what does that mean?
It means you have to learn how to develop
your teammates because not every team
you're going to be on as a winning team
and sometimes you're not going to be the
best player.
And so you better figure out how to going
to figure out how to bring those with
you up,
up in the developmental course.
And you better learn how to treat
your opponents with respect.
You're going to learn how to play properly
because then you'll be able to leave
the second of all possible soccer games.
So that's way better price.
And then you might start
seeing more complicated than
that because it is the set
of all soccer games.
That's the issue.
It's the set of possible games and
that's what they're trying to win.
And so how do you in the set of all
possible games or that that's the real
ethical question.
How is it that you conduct yourself
in life so that you maximize your
probability of winning
the set of possible gates?
Because that means that
wherever you're sat down,
you're going to do well,
and that's something
that you want to know,
that that's what it
means to have character.
That's what it means to be a good person.
It's not that you don't do bad
things because they're afraid of the
consequences.
That's not it at all.
It's that no matter
where you are in place,
you're ready and that's because he's got
a Cherokee as because to learn to play
the property.
As soon as you say,
well,
what do you want?
What do you want for your child?
You want to teach them how to play so
that everyone always invites them to play
games.
Because Nicole,
everyone says,
well,
do you want to play?
And then it wherever me know that's
what they did to do and you know there's
some of you in the audience who were
extraordinarily successful perhaps as a
consequences of your own marriage as
well as let's say the grace of God.
Part of that is,
but you know you play well with
others and so wherever you go,
you drop a reputation around you.
Maybe you're a little more
generous than you have to be.
Even maybe share a little more credit
that would be perfectly justifiable and
you go off,
you're waiting,
develop other people,
right,
and it's because you don't
care if you planned right now,
you're just trying to set yourself up
and everyone else for something way,
way,
way better than that,
and that's the purpose of the development
of character and that's a real thing.
It's not something statement.
It's not some arbitrary statement for
people who are easy going kind of finger
wagging morality.
It's not something that can easily
dismiss by oral relative to say,
well,
our culture is radically
different everywhere.
It's like,
yeah,
like the languages are
radically different everywhere,
but there's a core down there.
Then we don't just share
it with other human beings.
We share them with other animals,
which is why you can get
along with the dog fruits,
apple,
because if you have a dog in the door,
so it's at least in part because we're
playing fair with the dog and if you're
playing with a rope,
but the adults pulling on
it and he insulated dog,
little horrible noisy dog
and your political role is
it sometimes let the dorm
with enhance a little fit.
That happiness rating sheets,
the wrote back and forth,
but he runs around in circles.
It's like,
you know,
you don't have to be top dog for a
minute and then maybe he'll play with you
again.
So you're smart after you it with dogs.
And the fact that you know how to play
therapy with dogs indicates that there's
something about playing
fairly transcends position.
So one of the things I've learned,
I think this is so cool.
It's really what I'd be trying to express
what I turned from express tonight
because it's such an amazing idea.
It's just ever since I realized this idea,
just it's just I can't even think that
are just absolutely blowing me away.
So favorable,
not feel about this.
So imagine you have a game and
there's a way to play the game to win.
We already said why you need game,
right?
Because you have your purpose in life.
We'll call that an eight because there's
a bunch of different ways you could do
it.
So that's how you do it.
Even in a game you play monopoly,
you're goal is to fill the pool,
the money and you're like,
isn't the meaning to
your life momentarily?
Because it's a little
microcosm of reality,
which is why you play the game.
And so,
okay,
so now imagine there's gain single game
and there's a way to play it so that you
can win,
right?
But then we're gonna and
that's why the pyramid,
again,
I'm asking if there's a whole set of
those pyramids and then you can imagine
that each waiting to win in each of
those games is slightly different,
but there's.
There's commonality across stuff that
will be being a good sport plane fair or
something like that.
There's commonality across the board.
Okay.
Now,
so imaginative.
What you're trying to do is to set
yourself up so you're the best player no
matter what game comes up.
Okay?
So again,
it's more complicated than that too,
because then it has been.
You were trying to figure out what that
would look like because what you want to
be able to grasp it and articulate
it in representative because you.
Because help you act it out and it would
help you teach on people that acted
out.
And so that's what have
been doing for thousands.
Tens of thousands of years.
We've been watching how things work,
how people work.
We'd be watching the fact that we wouldn't
in hierarchies and that there's a set
of hierarchies,
and then we'd be watching and seeing,
okay,
some people are successful in moving
up these hierarchies of going out hard
because that's too limited.
The second hierarchies.
So then imagine that there's a
pattern that characterize this.
A person who tends to rise to
the crop set at all hierarchies.
Okay,
that's a mythological hero.
That's what the logical hero is.
And then pattern.
There's a pattern to that and it's
been recognized cross culturally,
which is why continually pops up
in mythology and popular culture.
So part of that,
part of that category is the willingness
to confront that you don't know,
right?
Because you think,
well,
how do you expand your ability?
You don't just hide and what you know,
you don't just stay in one game.
You don't think that's the total world
because what's your name falls apart.
We'll have you lost,
or what if it's a perfect game and
you went to Mexico catastrophe.
None of that's good.
You can't just be the
pastor of a single game.
You have to look.
I'll try not to have to open
yourself up to the unknown.
You have to always understand that there's
a bunch of things that you don't know
and
no,
I didn't see her again
in the knowledge center.
If you could open yourself up so the
white you don't know so you can interact
and what you don't know,
you can make yourself more than you
are and so that's the stance to take,
which is why in chapter one I ask
people to stand up straight with your
shoulders back because that's how
you expose yourself to the world.
It's a confident stance and it means that
you're ready to take on that which is
still beyond you,
and so that's what the characteristics
of the heroes that they hero voluntarily
confronts the on your
own and that's an old,
old,
old story.
It might be the oldest story.
It might be the story of matter of time
and now that there's more to the story
than not because the next
question mark people,
what happens if you do
open yourself up to that?
No.
Well,
you all know that already you die,
then you die.
Multiple deaths do that
so we know if when you,
when you stumble across something you
don't understand and it knocks you for a
loop,
that's often very painful.
Even if you've prepared yourself for it,
you know so you know perfectly well,
but those times in your life where
you learn what you needed to learn,
that didn't come up,
that incompetence of blood right,
if that's when you have a crisis
and maybe you heartbeat bloody well,
get through and and you're suffering from
it and maybe doubting the validity of
your existence.
It's like the worst thing that ever
happened to you and then you come out the
other end.
Saturday,
maybe budweiser,
but also more competent,
maybe more compassionate,
maybe wiser,
and you think whole path.
I went down into the underworld and I
came back out with it and that's the
pathway through life.
It's,
that's how you learn.
You're here and you're trying to
get there and there is better,
but it isn't a linear pathway.
If you want to get from here to there,
we usually go down first and
add up and so that's the best,
the hearables into the underworld,
to face the dragon,
to get the goal,
to emerge backup triathlete,
and to share that with the community and
we know that the oldest written story
we have is exactly that story that stick
a new dish or you do a image for me
from the Dantians is the Oxford story we
have and it's the basis of all so much
with what you watch is the basis of the
advantages and it's the basis of star
wars and it's the basis of star Trek and
all this mythology that you see all the
screaming as plugged in to replace our
religious preconceptions with the same
old material.
It's Harry Potter.
It's all of that.
I've been hearing partner dies
in this reform to overcome evil.
If you ever heard that story before,
a chest bone with curiosity,
that is what happens
is it is what happens.
Because like some of the times when you
encounter something terrible in your
life,
when you're moving
forward towards the goal,
what you've encountered might be the
terrible part of another person or maybe a
bb trade terribly by someone you trusted,
but they don't.
It's not not all that uncommon for that,
and that's even worse.
You know,
it's very,
very common for people who develop post
traumatic stress disorder to develop
because they be trained themselves,
right?
They saw them develop
posttraumatic stress disorder.
This happens in military and accomplish
a lot the person who watched themselves
do something so fruit don't make your own.
Imagine how we put it possibly has done
it and maybe they enjoy and then they're
never the same again.
And what that means is what made it
had an encounter with malevolence.
They had an encounter with evil monster
wave up to put and it's not in front of
and strong into that world
and half destroyed them.
And sometimes you don't get out of that.
Sometimes you do not recover from that.
This is real.
It's a real place,
the underworld,
and you could easily get dropped it,
but the mythological hero goes into the
underworld and this recording comes out
triumphant and that's the story of life.
And you'll do that on your way to
developing this ability to move up the
hierarchy.
Know.
So maybe if I can hear something,
it's also extraordinarily cool.
So imagine
there's a hierarchy between soccer game.
If you wait the game that you're
at the top of the hierarchy,
everybody puts you off on their shoulders
and they turn me around the field.
A field that's an indication that you're.
You're top boxster for a
moment and then you think,
well,
is there anything about that?
Is there anything above the painful of
the pyramid and raise different ideas?
It's about the pyramid
that had been denied.
The idea that you go
through the eye by a horus,
the Egyptian,
I find a bit of attention and it's above
the pyramid because the first thing
winds to Senegal Games is the victor
over the person who wins the single gay,
and that means there's something
outside each parent that's above it and
transcendent.
That's the ultimate value and that's
the idea of the king of all kings and
something like that and hero of all heroes
and that's an image that you call it
your imagination and you can identify
with you see it and calls to forward.
Because this has been going on for so
long while since rostered xbox $350
million years.
It's really a long time.
It's longer than their whiskey trees.
This has been going on forever
and we understand that.
We can recognize it even if we can't
articulate it and when you spontaneously
admire someone,
especially for a long period of time.
The reason that you environment because
they've manifested a fragment of the
behavior that makes a person a heroin.
Victor across sets of gates and that's
the person who's courageous enough to
take on what they will get
an understanding and let
the part of the Mideast
worthy or sufficient
parish as a consequence.
And that can be very painful
and that's part of the.
In the additional substrate
which the idea of the desert,
the resurrected savior emergence.
That's part of the legacy.
And so the idea that our
religious presuppositions
are religious reconceptualize
say the ones in which western or on the
superstitions is seriously wrong and we
don't really know the limit
of that because you know,
we don't know how good we have some sense
about how terrible and and Kevin Straw
person can be,
but we don't know how good nurses can be
and we don't know what you wouldn't be
like if you adopted the pattern of the
victor of the set of games that made that
your goal in life and you had the highest
school you can possibly conceive of
it.
You made that your name
would not be something.
And why not do it?
What the Hell's the alternative?
Well,
some of it is that sort of
bitterness and catastrophe.
Maybe that would be a good thing to avoid.
But who knows how far obvious.
Oh,
so wrong way up and you know,
you don't have anything better to do that,
David,
that.
And it's the adventure of your life.
There's no doubt about that.
And it's the only thing beyond the
deeply pessimistic person that many ways,
you know,
because I'm not naive about the depth
of suffering that characterizes the
existence for all sorts of reasons,
partly because I woke
as deeply as I could.
It took the atrocities that people are
taking bullets big during war time,
for example,
ordinary people to do
things he can't imagine.
They can do things so terrible.
They're just reading about the will
leave a mark on you that you can never
erase.
And then people suffered
terribly and their you don't.
No matter how materially.
Fortunately our life is a very brutal
business and there's no doubt that it's
painted seriously with malevolence
and evil and that's the landscape.
But people were unbelievably
unbelievable sources of future potential.
And maybe it's different if
it's some sentence in August,
I think about us.
I don't think of us as
determined creatures,
deterministic creatures that
money on our type like clockwork.
I look at a his creatures who face
against the landscape of possibility of
potential that's in front of us.
And then we transform that
intentional rejection.
All the partner of choice and our choices
are between what stood at what is not
going to,
what's good and what's evil live as the
choice we're making all the time in the
landscape of the quest and be making
those choices when we confront,
potentially take the potential is very
trump recently turned it into the reality
that we have and that we actually do that.
That's the consciousness ducks.
And I think that the idea,
and I made this up in my old lectures,
um,
I think the idea that human beings
are made in the image of God,
God being that force of consciousness,
let's say that use this communication
conscious communication structure
potential.
I do think that that's an accurate
description of what human beings are.
I do think that's the role
of consciousness and I
think that not only do we
construct a landscape of infinite
potential instream as we are,
but we also bring to that landscape are
constrained infinite potential that we
can release if we have
the courage to release it.
We released that by aiming as high as
we care about having the courage to tell
the truth.
And to ask for,
right,
we have to conduct themselves
properly in the world.
And you know,
deeply pessimistic as I.
I thought that idea more
powerful than the pessimism.
I actually think it's.
I haven't found an idea that I think is
more true than that and it's all taken
hamline tones to it because
I wasn't looking for an
idea that can be just taking
the first cohort comes along.
You need something.
You need a book that you
can be in during a storm.
You know what?
That's a boat and you
can be during the storm.
Putting yourself together,
back to your own best interests,
put things together for your family,
put things together for your community.
A high take,
the potential that's in front of you and
cast it to the world that you wish to
live in that dorm.
We have you do that.
That's what you do.
Whether you know it or not,
and that's why it's also true that the,
the destiny of the world and maybe more
than the world rests on each of our
shoulders.
It's really the case.
It's because the individual
is a very strange creature.
You know,
it's easy to think of yourself as over
7 billion people in the that what the
hell difference does it make what you do?
Well,
first of all,
you know that that's
not a good way to think.
You know what I mean?
You may not be able to think your way
of thinking that because you can make a
logical and compelling case for the
fact that you just the dust mote among 7
billion decimals in some corner of the
galaxy and what the hell difference is
going to make it 100 million years anyway,
but there's a part of you that knows that.
That's no philosophy to sustain
yourself with through life.
You know that and so you
can't fake your way out of it,
but you know that isn't what a person is.
As far as I can tell.
You're a divine locus of consciousness
and you are taking the process of
bringing order into Ba and you decided
by your people decisions whether that
order is going to be tilted towards
heaven or tilted towards health,
and if you don't believe that you should
read your fair share of 20th century
history and the hundreds of billions
of people who are who are killed and
destroyed the trade in prison can start
brewed by people who were clearly aiming
down and then you ask yourself,
well,
do you just believe that?
You just believe that?
That's down to just believe that that's
how it certainly close enough to help
for me and thinking if if it exists at
that matter will then the opposite of
that exists dogs or whatever
to the one from Auschwitz,
right?
That's where you're
having wherever that is.
It's not so easy to specify,
but it's.
It's at least we're.
That isn't term,
and you can start by making yourself
into the sort of person who wouldn't take
that path that was put in front
of the eye movement while you sure
people do.
Thank you.
So
I'm
going
to tell you,
if you're interested in doing two things,
you know,
in the upcoming weeks,
I just record the audio version of the
and 12 rules
for the work I did on that initial call.
I wrote in 1985 until 19.
I worked on it for about $3 a day just
to get the safe Taco.
It was very intense until I was trying
to address the question that I kind of
started with debate,
which is
reasonable that there's such
a thing as an epic universal.
Is that reasonable or is it just on?
No,
no.
I didn't know when I started working,
which can be the case because
I'd say to me in the beginning,
and it was probably more like,
it was just a little
arbitrary interpretation.
This is eastern 50 rationally know,
so it was a shock to me
to just start with that.
That was wrong and was a real shock
because it's really shocking to disturb
one thing when you're sort of at of evil.
You think religious metaphor,
it's remote.
It's like,
yeah,
I actually just really real.
It's the most real thing.
It's unbelievable to be real
and I do think it manifested,
manifested itself in a terrible place
in the 20th century as far as I'm
concerned.
It's no wonder people don't
like this idea around me.
It means normally for rocking,
just a physical in the sense
that he's done the ideas,
wanted to be involved,
but it's also existentially terrifying
to understand that in some real sense,
the weight of the world
is on your shoulders.
It reviews on your shoulders
and that's a question burden.
It's no wonder people
want to fly from that.
It's actually nice because people think,
well,
I'd like to have meaningful life,
you know,
because what's the alternative?
A life that isn't.
You don't have to do anything.
That's the big payoff for being nihilistic
and perhaps was just like it doesn't
even 100 million years.
It isn't that bad word,
is it a higher use that pretty much
eliminates any responsibility from your
world,
but if you're actually responsible for
things or that natural whole different
situation,
that means that it actually
matters what you do.
It really that it doesn't
just matter to you and Baxter,
everyone you know you're
networked with other people.
Well,
first of all,
I learned this partly a
variety of different ways,
but I've learned a lot by reading
about what happened in LLC,
Germany and in the Soviet Union.
Also.
I was trying all the other
terrible totalitarian states
because people debated.
Academics debated for a long time
about why those things happened.
You know,
one theory is,
well,
people are bad and so you get corrupt.
Leaders have to talk board,
been emulating the masses and then the
order perfectly good ordinary people to
do terrible things and that people are
terrified and serving that are kind of
like sheep or they're terrified and
then they go implement the malevolent to
dastardly plans of the leaders
and that's a pretty credible idea,
but it's wrong.
It's wrong.
It's like in a totalitarian
state like Nazi Germany or or,
or stokers Soviet Union.
Everyone was totalitarian.
Everyone.
It was bottom up and top down at the same
time and so everybody in that society
was responsible for what
the society was doing.
And I learned that by reading the
people who really thought about those
societies.
If Viktor Frankl is a good example,
he wrote a book called
Man's search for meaning,
which I highly recommend.
You know what Frankel's conclusions was,
that it was the proclivity
of the normative person to
lie and deceive the vent
to the excesses of the state.
The avoidance of responsibility.
As so as you said,
it's exactly the same thing about what
happened in the Soviet Union in eastern
Germany.
Nice journey.
One third of people were
government informants,
so you might number one,
it could have been convinced,
right?
Went back distance.
One out of three people.
So it means if you've got
a family of six people,
two of your close family members were
informing or you to a murderous machine,
and so that's the responsibility.
And so and so's netsuite and
other people have said the same.
If you stand up and crib line
that you can defeat a tyranny.
It's like,
well,
who the hell would ever get stopped?
Well,
go under estimate the power of the truth.
You mean why is the term so powerful?
Because it's true.
It's reality,
you know,
what are you going to do?
You're going to have an
argument with reality.
You think that's going work do,
yet you don't.
The only reason you ever
think that is that you're.
You're willfully blind to get.
He refused to view the consequences of
your actions or you think deep down in
your soul goes deep down
at the theological level,
way below your conscious apprehensions.
Wave along your political sentiments.
When you blow your philosophy,
believe you can get away with it.
There's an arrogant beyond comprehension,
and you believe that you can tweak and
twist the fabric of reality with your
thoughts and your actions at that.
Somehow you will be the
beneficiary of that.
Well,
good luck with that.
That's it.
That's all you have to think about that
idea for about a year because it take
about a year to thinking through what
is the possibility that that's true,
but you can take the structure of one
is at twisted for your own purposes and
have that workout for you.
That's not,
that's,
that's just not.
That's just not going anywhere.
That archaea all these people who go
tangled up with you still tell it to her,
even jeans,
you know,
they advocated through a
little personal responsibility.
They thought their lives didn't matter
or maybe they were willing to go along
for the sake of the vulnerability.
They have their reasons
because these robots machines,
but the consequences,
but everything around with people did
to hell blaming that on the leaders.
The leaders were manifestations of the,
of the metaphysical process,
you know,
and they aren't spending
along with the charisma.
But you know,
I read a lot about how Hitler figuring
out how to talk to the crowd because
really interesting because Hitler was
against the door door and you always want
to give the devil his due,
you know.
So what he would do is he talk to
the crowd and then he listened.
I've never said anything but the
angry crowd was excited about that.
He kept that and sort of became a master
app telling the angry crowd what they
wanted to hear.
What that meant in some sense
was that he allowed the product,
produced him.
And the thing about an angry
crowd is that an angry crowd,
he's made it individually so I can
block your right when you're right,
you're right and you're not
reading individually because
not be held accountable
for your actions.
You can hide your path,
log into the group and some of your
addressing on Bob and you want to rob you.
Then you have to tell the
paintings wants to hear me.
Maybe if you do that for five
years and you're really good at it,
you get it to be an absolute expert and
telling me a remark what it wants to
hear,
and then maybe that's how Hitler,
the German people created each other.
Unextended.
Everyone's participated in that.
It's not Hitler who somehow genius
benches that does this all by itself.
It's the bitterness and resentment of
badly lived rights that manifested itself
in the desire for a totalitarian leader,
finds a scapegoat that can be tortured
and tormented so that everybody could get
the revenge.
He gets gone.
That's essentially the proposition.
Thank people can do terrible
things intently in rule sets.
So now says
saying it's the perfect order before
you criticize the world and it's a good
rule to talk about tonight because
of what happened in Toronto.
So recently,
you know that I'm ready.
I'm not sure if this is correct.
Even if it is technically correct,
this metaphysical correct.
So it will give a of the trick,
if I remember correctly,
if I control that back and
drove it for 12 blocks,
is that.
Is that correct?
Okay.
Now you to think about that even though
you don't want to because who wants to
think about that?
Maybe you're unstable and angry and
see rick and now I'm going to see when
you're bitter,
you're driving your van and there
was a crowd of people and you think,
oh,
to hell with it.
And you step on the gas and the mold
out of three people right in and that's
that.
Okay.
Less.
You have to be in a pretty
damn dark place to do that,
but that is anything compared
to the place that you're in.
If you're going to drive on the sidewalk
for 12 blocks and you're going to take
people off one by one,
knowing full well what you're
doing and what in reveling in it.
I've heard it reported the next day
he called me up to talk about this.
She said she watched the young
man who perpetrated this massacre,
walked into the clock,
into the courtroom and she said it looked
like he was there to receive an award
and so that's something else that has
to be factored in and we don't like to
think about these things.
You know,
we don't,
we don't like because we might to think
even maybe that the person was oppressed
to the predictive buys two subsets
and that's why they turn and take what
beginners.
There's lots of old press people and very
few of them take a 12 blocks and take
out the Mrs. April and then I knew,
we hear well he hated women.
It's like,
why you didn't just kill women.
I mean certainly getting killed
mentor that had rejected him.
This was something far deeper and far
darker and it's a cannon to certain
situation that can actually
only be contemplated,
can only be understood using
something like theological language,
which is why I think theological language
actually exists because there are
things that are so terrible that there's
no way you can understand them unless
you use the white ones with good and evil.
You're just not even
anything in the right domain.
You have no idea where you have to go in
your fantasies to months and months and
months until you start thinking of renting
a van and drive it down the sidewalk
for 12 blocks and taking out into some
people is exactly what you should be
doing that day.
That's no wind band.
You've got some pretty damn dark places
before you get there and God only knows
what you need to those dark places.
It's the same with high school shooters.
These people plan and dream and fantasize
about the destruction that are going
to wreak right then and
there and they're doing it.
You see,
you think,
well,
why are they doing it?
Maybe it's a mystery that the
columbine kids that come from,
I remember correctly often for high
school shooters killed themselves.
I think that's what happened
with the columbine kids.
You might.
Why in the world when you go home,
the trouble when you say
it was a hopeless thing,
you're suicidal and people
get that way and you think,
okay,
well you're so hopeless.
Maybe your bitterly resentful.
Wife has dealt bad cards.
Maybe it really has.
If you think,
I just can't stand this anymore,
you go down into the base took and you
know you put a pistol under your hand,
but that's a whole different thing that
going to to the school and shoot up a
bunch of people and authentic
killing yourself because it's.
I call why bother with the whole murder?
What's the point?
Exactly.
You know you're not there anymore.
Why don't you just do the
world a favor so to speak,
and I skipped the first part.
The second part is the thing that you
should be pursuing or you're trying to
make a point in trying to
make some kind of point here.
Aiming at something.
Right?
You never know what you're trying to make
an appointment because they would give
you 100 million dollars for the
free publicity the next day.
If you to effectively make your
point on what's your point.
Exactly,
exactly what's exactly your point.
Why are you killing innocent
people who like kicking?
The guy went into the elementary school
in Connecticut and shot elementary
school kids.
You think,
well,
why would you go back through them?
They're so innocent.
It's like,
no,
you don't get it.
That's why you go ask.
I felt that a mystery.
That's the reason.
If you're going to extract revenge,
why don't we go after the guilty?
They deserve it.
If you're really after revenge,
you go after the answer because it's
more vengeful to punish the innocent.
That is to publish with
guilty and then you might ask,
well,
why don't you want to punish?
The innocent told us
is because your bitterness knows no bonds
is because you set yourself up as the
judge of existence.
The judge of being itself and the founding
of wanting in your estimation of your
own for revenge as a consequence and
the best way to conceptualize it.
It's revenge against God and you think,
well,
I don't believe when you
are in a situation like the
one we're describing what
you think you believe has almost
no bearing on the situation at all.
You're acting on eternal little drama and
it's contract with a person who shoots
his fist at the sky and
says how comfortable beating
of this nature possibly be
constituted.
Everything should suffer for the outrage
of its existence and I'm just the
person to make it suffer and that's
where we go with you want to shoot up the
high school and there's darker places
than that to have no one wants to
understand that because of the park,
because that's a bit
too close to the ball,
but also partly because it's.
It's a very terrible place
to revenge unoccupied.
You'd kind of don't understand those.
You're willing to take yourself and to
see the association would be people who
do not start at the darkest
corners of your own psyche.
Alright.
People had an unbelievable
capacity for some people,
that's all of us and it comes out with
all sorts of ways and most of us are
fortunate enough or well controlled enough
or lucky enough or good enough not to
hold those terribly dark places because
we're not capable of doing it and it
certainly the that could lead
sound around us constantly.
So what's the alternative to that?
The guy did this apparently.
Was it in of I guess idea.
He was rejected by rejected by women.
I got him for man.
Generally speaking,
if all you've ever approached you,
do you have to do is ask him
something wrong with you,
right?
If you're trying to jury of your peers
and they find wanting is always the
possibility that you're just not quite
up to scratch and then you might think,
well,
what should you do about that?
Well,
that's.
You might think,
well,
there is some good grounds for revenge,
right?
I could refile half of the human
race because they rejected me,
or the alternative is,
well,
maybe you might think about something
about yourself that could be improved and
that's daunting obviously because if
you have to accept that value that the
reason you're being rejected is that the
reasons you're being rejected or coffee
pretty damn d and that's
a bitter pill to swallow,
but what's the alternative?
Well,
the alternative is if you.
It's failure,
it's abject failure.
You're constant existence to misery and
resentment and brief and that just keeps
the ball rolling.
Again,
the ultimate endpoint of that kind of
thought process is exactly what happened
in Toronto.
I don't want to have the courage to face
the unknown because people are always
telling you what's wrong with you.
If you listen because everyone else is
everyone else in homes that they can be
more than they are because
everywhere you go you think,
wouldn't it be better?
Would it be good if I met someone
who was born and they are and they're
disappointed when someone isn't.
Be Interesting to talk to her when
they're jokes aren't funny or what?
They don't have anything
intelligent to say.
What would they be turning
a little bit cooperative.
You can't trust them.
You're deeply disappointing to me because
he couldn't be and so take as long as
you pay attention to what people are
talking and then they'll tell you what
about you and then if you listed the back,
you can start to fix what's not good
about you and he'll be somewhat better and
that's a lot better than taking the
murderous route to resentment and full you
on.
One of the things I really
admire the Old Testament Hebrews,
it's quite a remarkable thing.
I think this is one of the things
that gives the biblical stories.
They're immense.
Archetypical power is flat so that all
the time their societies fall apart
because they get very harsh wives,
very punished lives,
and often you know what they've done,
the things that would enable them
to preserve that sort of faith,
but the point is is that the old testament
is a rather brutal book and there's
no shortage of multigenerational failure,
but the one thing that he was constantly
refuse to do is to reject the idea that
the structure of existence
is five positive.
When they come to their senses,
they always think the reason that things
are impossible for us is because we're
not able to think we could
be and that's very much more,
what would you call it?
Productive Line of meditation,
and it's also much more optimistic.
Now.
One of the things I've really been struck
about while talking to so many people
is that,
you know,
for 30 or 40 years we've had this idea
that it's being promoted by psychologist,
the luxury good ones that you should
feel good about yourself and should have
some self esteem.
You should feel good about yourself.
I think that's complete rubbish.
I also think that people don't know that
that's rubbish and then it's actually a
really pessimistic thing to tell
people because most people are not.
Not everyone.
Many people are not satisfied until they
are or what their likes are and it's
painful and maybe it's because they're
too judgmental about themselves to harm
themselves.
That happens,
but it's over because they know perfectly
well that they're doing everything
they could be and IPO that they could
be beckons and an ideal as a judge.
At the same time.
One of the most brilliant
things I've ever read.
This was quite fertile.
You know,
he was very interested in why the book
of revelation was appended to the end of
the new testament because it's this
weird hallucinogenic psilocybin mushroom
trip.
You know,
it's a crazy,
crazy book full of this saying it's
saying imagery and in that book,
Christ comes back as the judge
with a sword coming on this device.
People into the damp and the
elected her not her many elect.
You know,
as a hell of a thing for
a failure of mercy to do.
But one of the things you have pointed
out was that an ideal is always a judge
and are something that really struck me
when I first read it because I thought,
well,
of course that's the case.
If you put something,
if you deposit stuff
has nothing to do with,
with,
with with the.
This is a psychological statement.
If you positive an ideal,
if your idea,
if you imagine who you could be if
you were saying that you could make,
I'd say,
and that sort of starts to shade it
to the idea of the mythological hero.
I mean that starts to shape me into
the idea of the Messiah and the Savior.
You start to imagine everything
that could be that you're not.
That's a terrible judge and
that's why that image is up.
The empathy that series of books is
because even if the ideal is all merciful,
just probably say how Christ is presented
in the new testament the judge has
missing and something that's perfect
as a judge and that we would come back.
And so that was extraordinarily useful,
but it also.
But he didn't let it take.
It's an indication to have the price
he paid for participating in the value
because we can pause,
we could be.
Then you're instantly ashamed
in front of your own ideal,
and I think it's appropriate.
I think that's exactly right.
I don't mean that people should crush
themselves with guilt because I don't
think that's constructive,
but if you think you have a
child that you turned to foster,
you don't tell the child
everything they could be.
You don't ever do that.
You say,
look like you're on the right path,
man.
You're developing your.
You encourage them to expand
themselves into the world and then say,
no,
you're not gonna compare to one.
You're going to be,
what are you going to be so great?
It's so great.
I'm lucky half laying
in front of him dead.
The fact that you're insufficient in
relationship to that is fine and then you
give them a destiny in the pathway and
one of the things that struck me so much
since I've been talking to groups of
about this size is how how captivated
people are by that idea because
they actually don't want to be told,
yeah,
you're okay the way you are,
so I'm probably going to
do go home and you know,
be in your film,
the bedroom and eventually your the bed
in box with bitter and depressed and
take more self esteem.
Thank you.
Start with small things and not an
works even starting permanently.
You know,
so it's chapter four,
which is a chapter above the alternative.
DMV says,
you should prepare yourself and who you
were yesterday instead of who someone
else's today.
It's like,
well,
who knows what your destiny is?
The onset.
It's a problem to comparing yourself to
other people who are successful because
those other people aren't you
and you're a peculiar thing.
I get a singular thing and what's good
for you in the truest sense is going to
be in the category of what's
good for other people,
but it's going to be an
idiosyncratic mortgage and circle.
If you're going everything you could be,
you can be bitter about that because
other people have more often the delusion
anyways,
although not always,
but you can get a tremendous way.
You can get a tremendous
distance by thinking,
okay,
well,
you know,
here I am and here's a bunch of
things that I know I'm doing wrong.
There is a good thing to think
about that slight confession.
That's what the Catholics
were trying to do.
You know it's brilliant.
We've lost that idea.
Ideas go somewhere once a week and
tell someone why you're pathetic and
well,
it's not something that you think that
you're pathetic and useless and so that
you can get one isn't so good about
you right here in front of you
and
me and Brian and you
know now otherwise empty.
You could have killed me.
Them some possibility that I could take
attendance step towards setting in a
second.
That's a tome I'm right.
That's redemption,
right?
That's,
that's the recreation of your spirit and
the resurrection of your relationship
with divinity that it's part of,
you know,
yes.
What that is.
It's the right way you're thinking about
and you can get there by admission on
the hour and that's why humility is one
of the fundamental religious virtues.
It took me a long time to figure
that out because humility,
it sounds like such a wretched
and pathetic virtual learning.
So humble.
It's like
that's my narratives but.
But that isn't it.
Like the humility is,
is that there's things you don't know
and they're really important and you
should be doing is opening
yourself up and thinking bad.
There was no learning is going to strip
me as soon as strip me of all my bad
habits.
No.
My debt would it be like
passing through a fire,
but I'm open to it as well.
I'm always locate to
see what I don't know.
I'm always looking to
see what's wrong with me.
That can be set,
right?
Well,
that's humility and you know there's
a lot more that you don't know that,
that you do know and you
might also ask your questions,
ask yourself,
well,
how well is what you know working for you,
right?
If you can,
are you who you should be,
are you who you couldn't be happy,
you the world right around you?
Or if the answer is no,
then what you know is to not obviously,
because what are you doing?
There's always things that you couldn't
be doing that you're not doing it,
so you have a lot to learn.
You know I wrote in chapter nine that
you should assume that the person you're
listening to,
those something you build,
and this is a great thing.
This is a really intermarriage I can.
I can tell you this.
If you want to improve your parents,
your relationship with your kids,
any intimate relationship,
this is something really worth knowing.
You don't have your children
or your wife and your husband,
her unbelievably annoying.
You have to live with her was wrong,
bro.
Everything I saw them,
but here's the things that even if 90
percent of what they're telling you is
wrong,
10 percent of these right now,
if your wife was criticizing you,
which is a high probability of error,
you have to help her figure out her
criticisms as accurate as possible and you
want to defend myself a go.
Fair enough assumption of
innocence and all of that,
but that's not the point.
The point is you're going to have to
play this game with her and hopefully you
would like again to approve across time
and the probability that you're carrying
some baggage along that isn't babies.
It's three high earnings for percent.
Listen to her.
Someone around with her and criticisms
one one.
Are you on target?
Anything?
Oh my God,
no,
I really stupid like that.
And then you favor because stupid people
fall into a pit when they walk more and
so maybe not being hit that you could
avoid and so well in mass and then it's a
so,
so you.
You listened to people as if they might
have something to tell you because
there's the off chance that they can
provide you with a bit of information that
would be not be so stupid as your down
and if you really understand that there's
all sorts of things that you have to go
right and then you're not doing great at
that you're not.
You shouldn't be or could be added.
That's actually important that you can
come out and maybe you're desperate and
you're grasping every time you'd
have a conversation with someone,
a little bit of truth that they might
be struggling to articulate that so you
can walk away with the
gold from the dragging.
Right,
because it's still fun
confronting and a response,
that's for sure,
but maybe they flannel in every direction
and try to hack you into ribbons,
you know,
because they're not very good
at pointing their criticisms.
But it is possible that if you listened,
God made man.
I truly out and like,
you know,
we're going to horrible itch,
but
definitely something that will make
me slightly stupid that I have.
Thank you.
So to recap,
set forth a set of propositions.
The first proposition is that there
is a very large number of ways of
interpreting the world and so that leads
us into the domain of horrible belt
visit.
There's all sorts of
horrors that lurk there,
but it's a powerful idea.
There's some truth to it because the
world is very complex and there's lots of
ways of looking at and maybe but then,
but then that's constraint.
We talked about how it
might be constraints.
Constraint is constrained by the SSS
necessity of planning integrative social
gates and also being
not only social games,
games that don't have the natural world
kill you as well because there's always
that,
right.
You have to conduct yourself in a way
that makes other people except you,
including your future self,
but you also have to not just die and
so that's another set of very powerful
constraints and then be foreign law.
Maybe there's a pattern to the bones of
being that fulfill those criteria and
maybe as human beings have observed
themselves over centuries or millennia and
we've crafted stories about
figures of good fingers of evil.
We be trying to do is to represent
that pattern that allows us to sustain
ourselves to thrive across the multiple
sets of ethical games that were played
and then it's not,
in fact the idea of the mental health,
human,
what we send out,
our deepest religious preconceptions
emerge and their branded an accurate
reflection of the way that people conduct
themselves in the world and that's the
ideal app which to me,
and that requires
and requirements.
The willingness to understand what that
what you don't know is more important
than what you know and it requires the
willingness to lay yourself open to the
fire that consumes it destroys
a you and it's a very,
very difficult thing to.
It's a very,
very difficult thing to submit to you,
which is where people don't submit to it
and it's no wonder that the rewards are
tremendous and their punishments
for not doing it as hell.
I think I'll stop with that.
Thank you.
After
number one,
thinking on your feet,
all these talks,
that gives me an opportunity to continue
to develop thinking about and also to
see what the consequences
of that are real time.
So I think that the BDC,
these talks,
they're not hear their
conversations and you might think,
well they can be because
I'm the only one talking
terms.
It's not true because people communicate
box of what we communicate with words,
but we also communicate with our facial
expressions and with our bodily posture
and with our our movements.
I can.
I can tell if I'm wanting to
something that's working properly,
I can tell because no one in the
audience moves and it's so cool.
It's.
It's the same reason to.
The rabbit doesn't move
when it looks at a wolf.
It's the same thing.
If it's the same cycle
physiological systems and it's.
It's the art part of your brain
that evolved to Dka predators.
These transfixed an idea
because the idea has the idea
has something that's inspiring,
wrapped up inside of it,
and you can detect that and so you
freeze and so I've known that I wanted to
something that has the same
archetipal significance.
If everybody in the audience
doesn't move and so,
but that's kind of what you want for
the talk is to see to see how much the
dining and keep the audience transfixed
in some sense and that transaction is so
interesting because it's a manifestation
of their instinct for being held so
because when you're.
When you're,
when you're,
when you encounter something meaningful
drugs to the encounter and what the
world is made up,
that's a very,
very concrete.
What matters in the world
is made out of what matters.
It really is Beethoven for practice.
There's two.
There's two definitions for that.
For that word.
We act like the world is data and Madison
and then when you encountered that,
that it transfixes you,
and so if you're speaking to an audience
and you're paying attention by watching
the audience because you're
not afraid of the audience,
let's say apprehensive of the audience,
but not afraid of it,
then you can tell when you're
pursuing a pathway that has,
it has substance and so it's
a great opportunity to to
communicate in real time.
It's a good example.
I think it's the best example of a very
good example of what free speech is so
important because see,
this is how you can fake
because you can't think,
oh,
because you're too stupid and
bias and ignorant and curriculum,
narrow minded and unidimensional
and so you can take a little bit,
but he can't really think to get your
thoughts out there and other people can
kind of fall on them.
In some sense.
That's the free market of ideas
that sharpens you up with your,
with your.
If you're willing and able to let that
opinion habits the way we were thinking.
No,
it doesn't mean that you're
blind follower if the crowd.
It's not the life that it has to
be more sophisticated than that,
but,
but uh,
so I don't care if I
get through the rules,
you know,
it's not because it's about the
process that generates the rules.
That's what it's about.
And a good talk is,
is that it's,
it's active participation in the
process that transforms potential into
actuality that African women last
participated in that because that's,
that's the core of the world,
that,
that's the core of the work.
So.
Well
thanks.
Have a great lesson
here.
What I was saying about
this week that I got.
Did you guys ever offered.
Okay,
so,
so there's an affiliate that there
will be picture that I think it's his
girlfriend and showed all
the people in the audience.
It was so great to be here with so many
peers in bed because he doesn't talk
about his daily life basically.
So
was
sort of a coming out coming out like
I'm okay with listening to ideas that
that's fascinating to me that people
in their regular life that Peterson got
that somehow controversial
thank in some ways because I think the
reason that uncontroversial most quite
ridiculous because
being painted with this sort of Albright
depressed from time to time because I
stood up against art stood up against I
suppose what I regarded as some of the
excesses of the 11th and one was
about the transgender program issue.
It's like I fought for a long time
ever since I started teaching.
I started teaching him to gale and I went
to Boston and then I came to Toronto.
I thought for years that if anybody
ever actually figured out what I was
teaching about health debate,
because honestly radical until
ridiculously rapid though,
the political radical part
of it is just surface noise.
I would say there's things underneath
editor way more than that because I really
do believe what I told him tonight.
I do believe that human beings are
divine locus of consciousness and I do
believe that consciousness
creates or from potential,
and I do believe that our wines are
fundamentally ethical and then they make a
decision between heaven and
hell every time we have.
I think those things are true.
In fact,
I think the neurological evidence
suggests that they're true of really
interesting conversation
with the Ian Mcgilchrist,
which you guys might
want to look up on that.
We're going to talk about that more.
I think these fundamental benefits of
presuppositions are the truest things
there are,
and so that's crazy radical and so we
probably shouldn't have listened to the
beach front.
Just go home and hide under
your bed longer than out here.
I guess we'll do a couple of
questions to asked me all the time.
What is Jordan like La Capra,
this,
this is the bad all the time by sharing.
This is the real deal.
There's a ton of great stuff here.
Uh,
so first off,
will you consider doing a guest
appearance on kind of these new album
trying lot of weird things that the
penalty in the last year and that's
certainly up there with the weirdness.
There's lots of things that have happened
to make it very difficult for me to
say anything and believe it or not.
And that's one of them and just I
can see you with a little blade.
I like this one.
How do you know when you give up on
something when it's not worth pursuing
anymore?
That's a great question.
Well,
I would say one,
one way of going to have
a viable alternative,
right?
I mean,
so let's say you know,
you've dealt with the pathway
and you might take well shit
on,
you know,
maybe,
maybe if you just,
persistence will pay off not just one of
the real complicated things about life
because it's harder to
tell the difference between
persistence and blind stupidity because
you should obviously steve versus the
things that are due to failure of the is
you can't predict what comes one of the
clinical practices and people were
doubtful about what they were doing.
We would look at their fantasies and
dreams because technically I think the
neurological evidence
for this is quite clear.
Your left hemisphere tends to impose on
the world a structured and predictable
wall and your right hemisphere looks for
exceptions out the normal ones and all
of those exceptions and anomalies
attempts to generate fantasies.
All my clients and you're
having a relationship that
you're trying to maintain
it when it's not very satisfying.
So we start having fantasies
about other people.
Well,
what's happening in your right hemisphere?
This is broadly speaking,
you know,
so forgive me for that.
For the oversimplification of your right
hemisphere is starting to tentatively
lay on alternative pathways that you
might pursue and so if you're wondering
about whether what you're doing is worth
doing and then what you might want to
do is sit down and make about three plans
and talk to someone who you can trust
and say,
okay,
if I wasn't doing this,
what else could I be doing that would be
approximately is difficult because you
don't want to fool yourself into thinking
you should stop just because what
you're doing these car and pretend
that that was because you failed.
You have to be careful so
you don't fool yourself.
You say,
well look,
I'm giving lay out three alternative
paths that are just as difficult.
They would also be worthwhile
and then I have some options.
Then you have to do the difficult things
necessary to ensure that those will be
launched and actually have what
might constitute a genuine choice,
and so that's how I would deal with that.
I love this one because someone
is clearly paying attention.
What's going on?
Just at the moment,
our friend Eric Weinstein coined a phrase,
the phrase this morning that I really
love all of our I he say is his selection
of writers who are constantly feeding.
So the question is what,
if anything should we do about the w,
r I t continuing to spirit?
You and your supporters as all right.
We talked a little.
I don't really think I
should do anything about it.
I think that the time for me to be
taken down except by my own stupidity is
maybe gone and so
no,
I'm
perfectly aware of how on all decisions
with how easy it would be for me too.
You've made a major error and to
suffer the consequences later,
but right now what's
happened and that's it.
This has been the case,
probably six that Catholic
newman interviewed,
but maybe a little bit before that
I can keep.
This isn't.
These criticisms aren't hurting me.
All these seem to be doing is drawing
more attention to what I'm doing and then
okay,
that's just fine as far as I'm
concerned because I've asked myself,
well,
what am I doing?
Hell No.
What?
What I'm doing is what we're doing here.
You know what I find most
gratifying is autonomous story.
Okay.
Because,
because Mrs.
so
you were a.
It became a New York.
Downtown colleagues is pretty rough.
There's places you don't want to go.
And I went to some of them.
I'm
walking around with my wife.
We were walking down the
street car pulled up,
you started this and this kid
walked out the stylish 21,
22 year old and he came running
up and you joined pinterest.
And I said yes.
He said,
Oh,
I'm so happy to meet you.
And he shook my hand and he said,
I've been watching your lectures and they
really helped me get my life together,
you know?
And I said,
oh that's great because
I do think that's crazy.
That's crazy.
How far would you like them?
And then to go to some city that you
haven't been to in a rough neighborhood in
the car comes running up
to you and telling you that
their license because they
want to be popped
store.
Wait,
wait,
wait a minute.
Just stay here a minute.
I said,
okay.
And he came home with
his father and mother.
They were both smart,
really smart,
you know,
like that kind of smiling,
just sort of car.
That's the Duchenne smile technically by
the way that you do with your eyes and
you're
looking for all place with each other.
With the kids.
I've been rescuing my father from
the belly of the beast basically.
Well now
he will come running up to me and
they tell me stories like slaves.
If if the balloon size,
you don't jump up and down about
what I'm doing and ignore all that,
that's fine.
Because I'm a psychologist.
I kind of just started a long time ago.
The locus of concern was individuals,
and I do believe what I told you tonight.
I believe that each person is a divided
focus of consciousness and that any step
forward to making someone's
life trauma better.
I don't mean easier.
I do not mean that to making it better.
Making them more responsible and more
awake and more attentive and more truthful
and more properly,
even farther away from hell.
It's like,
that's a great thing,
man.
So I don't care about the rest of it,
I mean it's a pain,
you know,
and it hurts I suppose,
I suppose
entertaining to be pilloried say the
national press on many journalists and
supportive to me and so I've
got nothing to complain about,
but whatever,
nothing worth doing is you see,
it wouldn't be any
interesting if it wasn't,
so I think I can just ignore it and
just try to do what I'm doing with these
talks.
So we'll see.
Thank you.
A school teacher and I'm seeing more and
more ideologies push on the students.
How do I navigate this landscape
and not jeopardize my job?
I get this.
How do you speak up?
The first thing that you going to
figure out your job's in jeopardy
because on the one hand it's jeopardy
because you might lose it and the other
habits in jeopardy because
you might have to keep it
five years of selling your soul.
As a teacher,
you're going to be one story character
and are going to see that with trump.
Sympathy like I'm not trying to be high.
You're prescribed both ways.
Sometimes it's useful to know that
because the problem is people often
overestimate the degree of security that
they currently have and so you might
ask yourself,
well,
what are you going to
look like in five years?
If you have to swallow that,
you have to teach it
because you don't oppose it.
Believe me,
there'll be no end to it because those
sorts of things don't stop until someone
stops because the people who are pushing
the limit and then he'll just push them
to go take another little
piece of your soul,
and so sometimes you think,
oh good.
That means I can do what I want.
Now,
that doesn't mean you
shouldn't be stupid about it.
You know,
and lots of people have
asked me this question.
It's like,
well sure,
I stand up against the creeping in
theology in high school as a teacher.
It's like,
Oh,
you have family,
you have kids.
Do you have people who are relying on you?
You can't just let yourself on fiber
protests and the little pile bash and
there.
Although it is true that
start with a good plan.
So what do you need to do
with your secretary kind of
smart and how often you go
to figure out,
you've got to think,
okay,
well I'm,
I'm in a war and a war is a sequence of
balanced and the smaller the battle of
the better and they're starting to
think strategically and you lay out your
options and have you had you fortify your
territory and shove it the tongue and
you decided that you're going
to do something about you.
Don't get all the impulsive that can
stand back and yelling at the principal
because he's maybe logical,
moral because you're just done.
What the hell good is that?
So if you know that your soul
is being corrupted by the logs,
then it's time to wake the hell up
and to start thinking and acting
strategically.
First of all,
you might want to lay out three options
for other employment so you know that if
he could come off at the nice to have
options because otherwise you've got so
much at stake and won't
be able to be courageous.
So when you notice that you stand back.
We up with these types of things,
it maybe you're into the adventure
of your life at that point.
It only ever know so they won't do it
impulsively or careless with the customer.
It's just not as useful
as feeding the cattle,
the snake in the snake like and windows
in an informed way and with some humor
and some detachment and and some care.
So it's a war going on and you
don't want to lose the warmth.
The first vowel is not
helpful so I like thank you.
Ready.
Would you please reconsider your
decision not to run for Prime Minister
Thatcher?
Like I've thought about
political career since I was 14.
I ran for vice president for the Elbert
met Peter and Stuart teeth are lost by
nine votes at 800.
So that was the first time I spoke in
front of a group and the first time the
press line,
which is
so fun.
I've always decided not to do it
because it's not perfect enough for.
Don't fake.
I mean I found repeatedly
throughout my life but.
But first of all,
it's not obvious to me that I know enough.
No.
Like are trained as a psychologist,
I know all this arcade material that I've
been talking to you about tonight and
I have a bit of practical knowledge,
but go out and you know,
being being a politician and running
something as complicated saves Ontario and
not much.
You'd have to study in order
to be really good at that.
We look at what's happened to her,
like our,
our hydro power grid and the utilities
don't target people that are going to
what the hell are you doing running them
and it's just a bloody catastrophe and
that's just a training every
thank.
I've talked to my wife about 30.
We had talked about it from
the Conservative Party.
Started moving closer to your
neck in Ontario three months ago.
I thought,
well you know,
particularly there are
supposed to take it.
And I thought,
Jesus,
I have to sit in my house
and study economics intensely
for like 16 hours a day
for a whole year before I could even be
ready to even contemplate the idea that
I could be safety competent to deal
with the sorts of things that have to be
dealt with them.
Is just so of,
and then the other part is I don't
think there's anything wrong with what I
currently do it.
Thanks.
I think we
took a detour to the political agreement.
See what I thought about with the
parents to the conservative government.
In turn it was,
here's the worst case
I run,
I win,
I win the election that
I got off the premium.
It's like what they.
That's not a lab,
a stupid plan,
so don't go in there.
I'm just not prepared for it,
but again,
like the risk of repeating myself,
I'm interested in something
that's deeper than that.
Not that I don't need more important,
but I mean more fundamentally
in a hierarchical way.
I really do believe that our culture,
a modern culture,
but particularly the modern Western
culture is fractured and that weren't in
danger because of that tractor and that
things need to be so back together and
that's a better.
That's for me,
that's a better thing to a map and I'm
more qualified to do it and so that's
where I should be doing,
so that's thank pretty sure
if Justin Trudeau can do it.
How much longer will initiate
the left to come back to center?
This as far as I can tell,
we set up a system,
particularly when universities were insane
radical leftists and those are people
who still harbor the suspicion,
real communism as the tribe.
Let's say that there are some stuff like
they figured out about a gender in the
subsidy for your activism and as
long as that continues to happen,
there's no possibility that things
are going to become more saying,
okay,
I think what will probably
happen in the next 50 years.
This isn't the only mind projection,
so there's lots of economists
have been working on this idea.
I'm gonna say 30 to 40 percent higher
educational institutes in the US and
probably go bankrupt in the
next 10 years and that'll.
That'll happen because there
just isn't sustainable.
I mean,
and so that's what I see
as the most likely outcome.
Assuming there is a likelihood
that he stays on this,
run themselves out to
the audit conclusion.
Now I'm not necessarily all that confident
about that because one of the things
I do see that now
is the same identity all takes.
Insanity is fading in the corporate world,
which is really a shock to me because
you think they're greedy capitalists who
have enough sense not to lead fifth
called radical leftist organizations,
but they don't seem to
have that much sense.
Just shows you that
they're not as malevolent,
as tiny as you might
hope that it would be.
So I think I don't think there's any
predictably charting the course of the
future for us right now.
I think that we're in a time of strange
crisis and the what will determine the
direction and the decisions that all
human people make me go back out into the
world.
You're already going to be sensible and
articulate and responsible and we're
awake and attentive or able to contribute
to the idiot chaos of polarization,
and if enough people decided
that the going to me awake then
knows can be,
but we get rid of the whole thing gone
wrong ourselves and have done that many
times in the past.
So
let's see.
Thank you.
How do you help someone
who's too afraid and a,
for example,
it's the same people
ask me to help someone.
Well,
first of quit helping them
because you're working,
so you have to launch and see it in the
viewer attempts to help are not working.
Then the not wanting to do this,
the right time for her to get her to
detached yourself with grace and with
compassion with the tennis.
But then you sit back,
watch all watched and merge the patient.
Um,
but in the meantime was
definitely more powerful.
An example,
if you want to change someone who doesn't
want to be changed the best way to do
example,
here's the better way to
do anything by example.
So that's,
you want to be an example to yourself too.
You know,
because why not?
So the thing that I've learned
about me and good person,
let's say,
and I'm not claiming
that I'm a good person,
by the way,
there isn't a banner,
there is better England.
There isn't anything that's more
adventurous than you possibly do,
that it really gives your life a depth.
It's almost,
it's an exhaustible and reuse things.
It's like there's a lot of things out
there that can be putting in an order and
you can put some of them in order.
It's like,
how much is that?
Can you do?
Who knows what?
What you can do if you
put your mind into it.
It's so fun because I see these young
young people come up to me and they said,
look,
I've really started to apply myself state
university and I are going to need it
and I'm starting to apply myself.
I think tell them it's like
great and guard yourself.
Half put together.
You're 21.
It's like he could be dead
by the time you're 30.
You can just be fixing things like map.
You can be competent in
10 different domains.
BBS,
force of nature.
It's like,
oh,
there is an ambition.
That's what we should be
teaching our young people.
It's like make yourself so competent
that you would just terrify,
get the hell out there doing everything
you possibly can to make things better
before the complain about
the structure for world.
Right,
and they're so happy.
You tell the kids that they just smiling
away site because that's what they want
to hear this.
They want a pat on the back,
not because of what they've already
accomplished with because they're on the
path to something greater
and it's just vigorous.
I'm wondering,
one of the things that's so fun about
all this is on the lead executive for
people because there's thousands
and thousands of letting you know,
they say the same thing.
It's like doing my best said,
put my foot forward and to step forth
into the world and to tell the truth and
reporting in on getting along with
my girlfriend or my boyfriend.
The getting along better with my parents.
I'm doing good at school and you know,
here's a bunch of.
I'm excited.
Dropped and cycling man.
Come forward and see what.
No,
it's so good.
So
thank
stress surrounding the problem
that is out of your control
now.
I've had problems for a long time now
for the last 10 years and my daughter is
just unbelievably sick.
I'm worried about that.
Chapter 12,
you know,
sometimes you just don't,
and that's part of the
catastrophe in life.
You know,
some people get panchromatic
counselor and they're done.
They're done in six months.
Then all the heroes in the world is going
to save them from a particular faith
is heroic idea,
you know,
need,
despite the best of your life,
it's your best back by any
stretch of the imagination.
It's also the best approach you how
to actually fixing the catastrophe,
but you know,
still bounded by your mortality
and your and your insufficiency.
If you really take care of your sick.
Part of what you have to do
is shrink your timeframe.
When we were dealing with landowners and
she was well on the way to parishes and
in the very painful manner,
um,
you don't think about a week from now,
a month from now or a year from now,
you think about today and you think,
okay,
well,
I'm going to make today's
lit as I can make.
And then sometimes you
don't think about today.
You think about the next morning and
sometimes you can lead you to think about
that.
You get to the next hour
or maybe the next minute,
someone's deathbed,
it's the next minute,
you know,
and what you do is try to make that the
least amount of horrible it can possibly
be and that this really matters.
One of the things that struck me,
I was,
I was around,
my mother belonged to Steph and she had,
for example,
dimension,
which is a particularly nasty way to go
and it took her quite a long time to in
the final throws,
the realness.
It's rough to be in a situation like that.
I guess the person that everyone loves
us to Sharon with the former self and a
skeletal without the family old,
their.
The person's in an agony,
you know,
because dieting a snuff for the week,
that's for sure.
But my sisters,
my wife's family are
quite an admirable law.
My wife was statistic value term work
and his work as a social therapist and
she's a tough cookie and her sister is
a palliative care nurse and her other
sister was a pharmacist and they're
pretty sensible as a family and you know,
they all around the
monitors with their father.
The beginning,
right,
it only pulled together.
They didn't fight when she was dying.
They called together and when I saw half,
of course it turned.
The situation that was determining tragic
into was it had something knowable,
love it to spray this catastrophe and
certainly didn't deep generated into a
squabbling hell,
which could have easily happened.
They actually gained something from it.
I think the family became closer
afterwards because of what they had gone
through and their mother was closed,
but they all know along better after that,
and they were all closer to the father
was an absolute star during his wife
sale.
He was isn't interest to God.
He's still alive.
Stickiness.
Tell Robertson he was he money knew
of in this little town I grew up in is
unbelievably extroverted in a comical guy.
Tended to drink too much and
he was the wife of the party.
Loud guy.
I gave a far more labor t shirt for
Christmas one year and she proudly.
It's kind of a party animal,
but I'm also very solid manner.
I really liked him and respected him.
God and his wife got sick.
He was.
He was something else that he took care
of her like patiently and every time
someone offered to help them,
he thought it would help me,
took the hill and he was happy that he
garnered the respect of his children in a
really profound way and so well.
So what can you do in
a terrible situation?
This you can.
I don't want to say it lightly,
to make the best of it.
You know you could stop it from
degenerating into absolute hell.
You can do everything he can
to stave that off the partner.
You do that by narrowing your timeframe.
It's like if,
if the week is too much that it's today
and if the day is too much debt is to
our hours too much,
then it's the minute you think,
well hell,
I have to get through this next minute.
I'm going to do it the best I can,
and then it's the next
minute that sometimes that's
going to go up that shoulder
against the wheel.
Brutal uphill struggle and hopefully you
can do it as normally as you can manage
and that's.
That's the best you have in
some situations and it's a
hell of a lot better than
the alternative.
Thanks a ton of great stuff here.
So I'm just sort of
randomly jumping around.
I love this one.
How you find your passion.
Well look,
you know,
everybody has a problem and you might.
That's terrible.
You don't.
When you think about all
the problems in the world,
there's walkable kind of all your
problems and then we can tell that some of
them,
even though there are problems,
you know,
maybe their problem if you work
with other people are politically,
they don't bug you have some problems,
but you.
And if those are your problems and so
you sort of find your destiny in your
problems,
I would say something bought you,
fix it.
You know,
maybe you want to pick
the right sized problem.
Don't,
don't get all Arabic trying to fix
something you don't know how to fix.
But if something's been see you,
well that's your problem.
And then there's,
that's your destiny will fix that problem.
And we can do this in local environments.
You can go to the room.
That's kind of funny that this whole
clean your room thing is become a thing.
I mean
there's a reason for that is because it's.
It's,
it's humbled in the right way that he's
not that easy to clean around matching,
especially if you live in a
really dysfunctional family
because if you live in a
really dysfunctional family,
they will get really angry at you when
you start to do things right and then
then you're in a battle that,
and that might be as simple as male.
Do you think you are when you're doing
something like trying to remove some of
the grime and the catastrophe that
happens to be part of your living space?
No,
because just by taking a
step in the right direction,
you shoved in dim light on everyone
who's groping around in the dirt,
trying to make things worse,
and so trying to clean up the room
to be a real metaphysical battle.
The camp,
because the room is a microcosm,
you know,
it's also,
they're part of reality that you
have a grip on that you could set,
right?
You could learn how to live with him and
it's the right level of humility that
you might be able to clean up your room.
You might be able to send in an order.
You might even be able
to make it beautiful.
If you've got an ambitious,
you know you can make the little
place that you have control over.
Beautiful.
That's a real difficult thing to
manage and so now I've got an question.
That question
that you should take,
you should take.
You should take your problem with
seriously because you know me.
Branded stories.
Abraham in particular is called
by the adventure of his life.
Not only does encounter trouble like
storage are so comical because garden
basically tells him to get
up entrepreneurs gas in
it and he's been hanging
around as far as camp for way too long
goes out into the world and there's
nothing about a catastrophe.
The younger parents like
would it be better to stay
at home and the 10th that's,
that's not.
It's not right because it's like the
problems in your life or here are the
portal to your great advantage of like
the question with the high school teacher
after a cycle,
how do I stand up against?
It's just like exactly.
You're in position of the potential
mythological hero who has handled through
the tire was sea of clay.
It's like,
how do you do that?
You transform yourself into warrior.
That's how you do it,
and then that changes
everything about you.
It's like,
well,
it's terrible that I have this wrong.
It's like,
yeah,
it is terrible,
but it's also the greatest thing that can
happen to you and so look and see what
your problems are and then off that set
of things that manifest themselves as
your promos.
Look for the smaller subset of things
that you can fix and start fixing them and
you'll get better and better and better
app and then who knows where you'll end
up and then you will
find yourself that way.
And so it's kind of painful,
you know,
because you have to pick up the problems,
but don't be so sure if you want to have.
Get almost like that
would be very interesting.
So maybe whatever compelling
problem that grips you completely.
Well,
you could probably find one of those,
so that's what I would recommend
and be humble.
Like you don't maybe want me some
little trivial things you can fix.
Well that's probably all you're good for.
Anyways.
Your job go well,
I'm fine.
I'm a little better at this
than I might've made it so
that maybe you could try
like a medium sized,
but Carl Jung said,
monitor people don't see,
don't look low enough.
I love that.
He's so smart.
Terrifying,
but smart.
But that's a lovely idea.
It's like there's something
out there going for you.
You're too damn hurricane to bargain with
it because you think you're above it.
You're not humble,
so down on your knees,
so to speak.
He looked for the parole is small enough
so that you're the right size warrior.
Combat that particular
tiny dragons and you think,
well that was pretty pathetic.
It's like,
yeah,
it was to begin with,
but not for all.
So
thank you.
This is,
what would you say were streaming?
What would I say that Arla?
Well,
if you say to them,
if they,
you have some followers
that believe in things,
you don't believe that extremism.
So I think if there are people,
there are people with like,
you know,
the search
that we find old reasonably regardless,
recognizable thing that I have
an Avatar for their viewpoint.
They're not my followers.
They just repeat to take the paid
understand why it might be because we have
some casual acquaintance with the fact
that I've criticized the radical left.
It's like,
no,
I'd be lecturing about the
same things for 30 years.
One hundred one.
Have I been telling if you want to,
Nazi Germany can probably be anoxic.
No,
I spend about 30 hours trying to convince
my students that that's the truth.
It's like it's a bitter bloody truth.
What are you going to do?
You're going to take that as a message
to transform that into some political
crusade that's going to make
you feel like it all right?
If your own.
Because he admitted that and
you understand what that means.
To admit that if he would
have been announcing it's
occurring in a phone me and
have that as the best can make that some
sort of political tribalism and if you
don't get,
if you don't get that core message,
you know that the evil of the
world resides with the video.
If you don't get that core message,
you haven't missed anything that are
saying because that's certainly what I've
been saying.
No,
take on the burden of malevolence.
Don't project it on work and straighten
yourself up because the world depends on
that.
It's like people can turn to make
political hay out about the good luck man,
because that's just,
it's just not a story that transforms
itself into the ideological wether easily.
So go back to those people.
I don't think I have followers on,
you know,
I don't like that idea.
Never have followers.
It's like you don't have followers.
Please pick up your guard,
their burden and struggle up the hill.
I saw something that
you have fall restore,
that's a cold.
Each person's individual destiny.
And that's not.
There's nothing in that for followers.
Like
thats last important.
Zach.
No,
but we achieve it.
You should forgive those
who trespass against you.
It's like you haven't.
It's pretty hard to do that.
You don't do that just by
waking up one morning and say,
I forgive you.
That's.
That's the part that hasn't
forgiven at all.
I mean,
first of all,
you want to ask when you
should forgive someone,
no.
Forgiveness is associated with repentance.
Now let's say that someone
will be traded and seriously,
or even you'd be treated yourself.
Let's do that.
You betrayed yourself.
You know,
you think,
well,
she'd be forgiving yourself.
In fact,
I'll tell you,
learned your goddamn lesson now until
you come to your cell phone in your hands
nice and say,
look,
here's the periodic ways that was foolish.
Blind like an exhaustive accommodated,
and here's what I'm going to do.
Here's what I've already started to
do to put it right or do you allow me
another chance?
That's and then that forgiveness
is because this justice to right.
There's not just mercy.
There's also justice.
You can throw a whole justice,
no proceeded mercy.
It doesn't work that way and so you
want to forgive if you can because why?
Carrying with you if you don't have to,
but forgiveness requires
repentance clearly.
Otherwise it's just
application of responsibility.
You don't forgive your job for doing
something stupid so easily because all you
do is encourage them to do stupid things.
He say,
well look,
you did something stupid like,
well,
can you forgive me?
It's like,
okay,
what can you do those stupid.
Exactly.
Why didn't you do it?
How is it likely that you're not
going to do it again in the future?
Can you convince me of that?
And he don't want to let your kid off
easily with that because you don't want
them to them the same
stupid thing to feature.
So if they don't understand it,
they don't have an alternative
plan and they haven't repented,
then what the hell is what good
is it to forgive them so I get it?
Yeah,
no problem.
Can go do it again so that to you,
that's not love,
that's not locked office turned to help
the person not doing the same stupid
thing again.
Sometimes you have to hold
someone's foot to the cold,
so to speak,
you know,
and say,
look,
I see what you're doing and you're not
going to get away with it because it's
not good for you.
That's
forgiveness is not the only moral virtue.
Stretch to the imagination.
Just like compassion is
not the only moral virtue.
So all.
Well,
we've got time for one more.
This is probably the appropriate,
what you mentioned,
consistency consistently had a goal in
life and when you say that yours has
changed after you released your book,
so right now as we begin this tour,
is your job,
your goal.
I want to do a good job,
a snore.
That's my whole flipping
out about six months later.
I don't think I can look any farther than
that because the landscape is changing
very rapidly and I don't
know what to make of it all.
Not even a bit,
but I know why you would
have some touchstones.
This seems worthwhile.
I mean,
I enjoyed doing it.
I'm extraordinarily pleased.
Thanks.
We'll talk to 100,000 people
live in the next two months,
something like that,
and so I'll try to concentrate on
making this is part of shrinking the
timeframe.
Do you know?
It's very busy.
I try to concentrate on the property
as the big has sufficient people.
They're off,
let's say,
and then I can come and talk to audiences
like audiences have individuals like
you and we can make a little
progress to say to kids,
right.
That's great.
As far as I'm concerned,
like I can't think of anything that could
more worth doing than that and so and
hopefully I can do that credibly over
the next six months that I've been
building a kind of structural
infrastructure underneath
vs because this is God,
this is whatever this is has taken on
kind of a life of its own and I've had to
build a management structure underneath
it to make sure that it works properly.
As a creative artist,
agents,
artist,
agency in La,
it's been helping me set up this tour.
They've been unbelievably helpful.
They're so competent,
but just a pleasure to
work with is thinking.
It's just going so smoothly,
you know,
Dave's been given me a hand
and I think that's great.
And um,
so I'm concentrating on making sure that
these folks are alive and real and then
building the technical infrastructure
around all this to make sure that it goes
smoothly as possible and hoping that I
can concentrate on getting that property
at the highest level that I'm incapable
over the next six months and we'll see
what happens.
This is another thing that's cool.
This is something to really think about.
It's one of the best things
that I've ever learned.
There's some real is something
about telling the truth,
which is rule eight,
if I remember correctly,
the rule is to tell the
truth or at least to apply,
you know,
if you say what you think and you have
to do this carefully and you have to know
what you think and you have to watch it.
So it's not an easy thing,
but it's so incredibly adventurous.
It never bored.
No.
Because if you say,
what do you think?
You don't know what's going to happen.
God knows what happened,
like all sorts of weird things will
happen that you might not cope with them,
but I'll tell you,
you're not going to find.
You can see this white.
The idea though of telling the truth
is associated with the idea of faith
because there's a proposition and it's
laid out in the first chapter of genesis
and the proposition basically
if something like this,
if you wanted to express it sort of
psychological language that the being that
you bring into mediating by telling them
the truth is the being that is good,
so that's a proposition.
It's like an axiom of faith.
He said,
well,
that the universe is constituted so
that whatever you bring into being by
telling the truth is is good,
but it doesn't necessarily manifest
itself that way in the moment.
You know,
because good is really complicated,
right?
Something can be terrible at the moment
and then turn out to be pretty damn
good.
That's happening with a
lot of these protests which
were unbelievably painful in
the moment,
like the one I'm queens,
which was just an
absolute Zombie nightmare.
Talk about,
we'll get an audience,
we're afraid it this really uncanny but,
but it unfolded well as progressed
and so I decided a long time ago,
probably 30 years ago that I was going
to be fairly careful with what I said I
was going to watch every word I said and
every word that I wrote and see if the
words maverick as if they really mattered
and now I'm supposed to say what I
thought carefully and let whatever
happened happen no matter what it was.
And
if you're looking for an adventure man,
you do that,
you'll have your adventure.
That's for sure.
And so,
well that's what I'm trying to
see the limits of that I guess.
No,
it's like I wrote that whole being and
that'd be lectured them on time and
successfully,
you know,
the students have really responded to it.
Then for whatever reason,
now it's very crazily distributed.
You know right now on youtube,
people are making 4,000 videos
go week about my videos.
So it's,
it's absolutely.
I'd have to say what to make of it,
but
we'll see how it plays out.
I'm gonna try to do it as well as I can
and watch what happens because I'll tell
you it's,
it's not dog.
Thank you.
I just want to thank you for
letting me be part of this role,
but more importantly,
it's an honor.
I mean the things they eat better.
It's still a work in progress,
but I'm honored to be part of this and
I can't wait to see what the next two
months brand for all of us.
So,
uh,
give it up.
Thank you.
Hey,
congratulations.
You made it to the end.
Thanks for listening.
Hope you enjoyed the talk.
I know.
I really did.
At some points I felt like Peterson
was speaking directly to me.
Like when he says you've got
yourself half put together,
you're 21,
it can be deadly by the time you're 30.
I'm 21 myself and I feel like that's
incredibly encouraging for me.
I felt like I've been a mess
for the last 20 years at least,
and it's only been this past year that
I've been trying to improve myself for
the better.
Here's some of the other inspiring things
that he said that I especially took
note of.
You want to be an example to yourself.
You can be competent in
10 different domains.
You can be a force of nature.
Make yourself so competent
that you're just terrifying.
Another thing I particularly enjoyed was
when he was talking about people such
as myself,
people who have been inspired
by what he's been saying,
uh,
he said that referring
to people such as myself,
they want a pat on the back,
not for what they've done,
but because they're on the
path to something greater.
And I felt like for most of my life I've
been told to be myself and to accept
myself for who I am and I could never
really take that advice because I didn't
really like myself and I
didn't really know who I was,
who this person was.
So I felt like that advice
was just lost on me.
But I think it's great to
hear that you can transform.
If you don't like what you are,
you can become better.
You can transform into a warrior.
That's another thing I
really liked that he said,
transform yourself into a warrior.
That's exactly what I want to do,
you know?
Anyway,
I know you clicked on this
video to hear Dr Pearson speak,
but if you like what I've been saying,
please consider subscribing for more
Jordan Peterson psychology and philosophy
related content.
Thanks for listening.
Have a beautiful day.